We just finished exploring the MetaHuman Creator face controls.
Next, we continue our journey with the MetaHuman Creator by looking at the hair controls.
So, let's jump back into the MetaHuman Creator.
Now, let's take a look at the hair controls.
If we select the head and go to Style,
we can see a variety of hairstyles we can choose from.
For the hair color, you can choose from any of the presets,
and you can also choose from neutral, deep, or vibrant colored presets.
And you can create your own custom color.
If you want to further customize the hair, you can go to the Details tab.
You can adjust properties such as the roughness, salt and pepper, and salt and pepper lightness for the main color.
Depending on the hairstyle you have selected, you will also have the option to enable ombre,
which starts at the tip of the hair and spreads upward.
This has its own customizable properties, such as color, shift, contrast, and intensity.
You can enable the highlights, which controls the balance between dyed and natural hair strands.
You can adjust the color, the color blending, the intensity, and variation.
Just as we have hairstyles we can choose from for the head,
we also have some options we can choose from for the eyebrows and eyelashes.
For the eyebrows, we can select any style we want,
and adjust the color and the details for these independently from the head.
Depending on the brow style you choose, some may have in the Details panel
the option for shading and microblading.
Moving on to the eyelashes, having options for the eyelashes can be helpful,
especially when working with more custom metahumans.
For instance, your character may have a unique eye shape,
and you might prefer the lash placement of one style over the other.
The eyelash color can also be customized and has its own color details.
I will go here to turn off the toggle clay material.
For the mustache and beard options, these also have their own styles,
and there are a variety of mustaches and beards you can choose from.
Now depending on which style you select for either of these,
some will also have the color options such as ombre and highlights.
Before we move on to the body controls, let's do a quick review of the hair controls.
For the hair controls, we have a variety of styles and colors we can choose from
for the head, the eyebrows, the eyelashes, the mustache and the beard.
When you select a color for the hairstyle, that color is applied to all the other grooms.
You can change the color of the other grooms independently.
Now depending on the style you have chosen, you will also have a few other options
you can configure such as ombre and highlights.
Depending on the eyebrow style you have selected, some may have the additional option
to choose microblade and makeup shading.
Now that we've looked at the hair controls, let's continue by exploring the body controls.
Now let's take a look at the body controls that allow us to customize the proportions
and add contemporary clothing such as tops, bottoms and shoes.
Starting with the proportions, we have 18 unique body shapes we can choose from
based on height and these are short, average and tall.
Now we can choose whether we want to have a feminine or masculine body type
and we can choose if we want our character to be underweight, overweight or normal.
There is also a head scale slider over here if we wish to adjust the head size in relation to the body.
For the clothes, starting with the tops, these contemporary styles also come with a wide variety of patterns.
These patterns can be applied and further customized.
If we wish to remove the clothing, we can select this option over here.
For the pants, we will also have a few contemporary styles.
Some of these options will also allow you to select from a variety of patterns.
If we wish to remove the pants, we can select this option.
Lastly, we have a few different styles of shoes.
There are no patterns or additional detail options for the shoes other than the color options that are available here.
Now before we move on to the animation toolbar, let's review the body controls one more time.
For the body controls, we can choose the proportions based on height, feminine or masculine and body weight.
A quick note is that the female medium normal body weight metahuman will always be the metahuman based skeleton.
For clothes, it is worth mentioning that they are contemporary.
So if you are looking for something different, there are several options for metahuman custom clothing on Fab.
Now let's move on and take a look at the animation toolbar.
If you want to see what your character looks like with all of the customizations you have applied,
you can use the animation toolbar to apply a variety of body and face animations.
Starting with the face, if we click on the vertical ellipsis and select a facial pose over here,
we can see what our character looks like when making certain expressions.
We can also select the facial rom animation and see a variety of expressions on our metahuman.
This is especially useful when testing out changes you have made to the face, such as wanting more prominent wrinkle maps.
This is also very helpful in spotting problematic areas while working with more customized metahumans,
as you can identify those and make changes on the spot before bringing it into the engine.
You can also choose from a variety of body poses or animations,
and this is helpful if you want to see what the body proportion you have chosen looks like when your character is in a certain pose.
The body rom is especially useful if we want to see what our character looks like in motion, perhaps with a specific clothing style.
The animation toolbar can help you make decisions on the spot based on how your character looks when the face and body come to life.
We can also use this to see what our customizations look like with a variety of lighting scenarios and camera positions.
Let's do a quick review of the animation toolbar before we move on to a few other things we can do with the metahuman creator.
We have just looked at the animation toolbar, which includes a number of body and facial animations and poses that we can apply.
The face animations are particularly helpful as you can see with the wrinkle maps and adjustments to the face look like in the event you want to change something before bringing it into Unreal Engine.
Some of the facial animation poses we can access inside of our Unreal Engine project in the metahumans folder located in the face pose library folder.
The body animations can be helpful if you want to see what different proportions and clothing options might look like when your metahuman is in motion.
We have just seen what is possible inside of the metahuman creator by simply selecting a metahuman preset and using the various tools to further customize it.
There may be times where you might want to share a metahuman you have created with another user.
So let's jump back into the metahuman creator one more time to go over the process of how we can share metahumans with other users.
Inside of the metahuman gallery, let's go over how we can share metahumans with others from here.
With the metahuman we wish to share with someone selected, we can go to the bottom left panel over here.
In this panel, we will have the option to permanently delete a metahuman or create a duplicate.
And over here we have an option to import an mhb file and export an mhb file.
If you select export, a progress bar will appear and a copy of your metahuman will be downloaded as an mhb file.
If you want to import an mhb file someone has shared with you, you can click on the import option and choose the mhb file.
And that metahuman will appear in your My Metahumans gallery.
Alright, let's review everything we've just covered before we move on.
We have just seen how we can export and import metahuman creator files in order to share our metahuman characters with other users.
It can be helpful to share and receive metahuman creator mhb files so that you can work with other users on the same character.
If you wish to share a metahuman with someone, in the My Metahumans gallery, use the panel below to select export.
The mhb file will be downloaded and you can share that file.
If you want to import an mhb file someone has shared with you, you can select import then locate the mhb file.
A progress bar will appear and that metahuman will appear in your My Metahumans gallery.
We have explored what we can achieve inside of the metahuman creator, but there may be cases where you want to push for more likeness with your character.
So this brings us to the next section of this course where we go beyond the metahuman creator and use the metahuman plugin for Unreal Engine to create a character from an existing 3D mesh with the mesh to metahuman workflow.
Thank you for watching.